my job is to just say that chris is one
honey meaning he's a he's a good dude
was it rolling chris got arrested today
was it was I think it was wrong and this
is sad and it hurts my feelings that you
worked so hard to try to get better and
a small little length of a story that
you don't even know is even real or not
can't affect you this much without even
getting the facts okay let me just run
through a few things that she said she
said there were guns there okay she said
that it was an argument over jewelry
okay and that he pulled a gun and put
her face and then after she walked out
then a car followed her okay that
truthful listen I can't say what's true
for not because I've never seen that
happen and I was right there so I don't
I don't want to comment but if you have
the truth that can in the end exonerate
Chris it's important to get that truth
out there isn't it that's why I'm here I
mean everything I'm everything you're
saying is ridiculous to me what's going
on let's figure this out